[Musique]
les oiseaux profitent ils du
ralentissement des activités humaines
liées à la pandémie
il est encore trop tôt pour le dire mais
une chose est sûre le paysage acoustique
a changé de façon dramatique le
vrombissement des voitures et des
camions a cédé la place aux chants des
oiseaux pour le plus grand bonheur des
ornithologues
e
c'est sûr qu'elle capte tourments que
c'est un des meilleurs endroits si c'est
pas le meilleur endroit dans la région
pour observer les oiseaux
ce qui est dommage c'est que ces temps
ci on est en pleine migration
printanière
alors il ya beaucoup d'espèces qui
commencent à revenir ici on pense aux
oies blanches bien sûr mais il ya aussi
cou de canard
les patrons ont commencé à arriver
bientôt donc ça fait un peu deuil pour
les ornithologues quand tout est fermé
même les parcs et les réserves
naturelles c'est tout un pan des
collègues de données scientifiques de
terrain qui est sur pause
je pense entre autres aux relevés des
oiseaux nicheurs qui existe depuis 1966
qui est une source majeure de données
sur les oiseaux qui a été annulé à la
grandeur du pays à nous à québec oiseaux
on a des inventaires d'étourneaux de
martinets qui ont dû être annulés donc
ça touche beaucoup beaucoup de gens avec
toute cette histoire de confinement les
ornithologues lui c'est clair qu'ils
changent leurs comportements
donc moi je connais beaucoup de gens qui
de québec qui ont l'habitude d'aller
observer les oiseaux montréal au
printemps et vice versa mais le monde
reste un peu chez soit en it all of
professionnels ou amateurs doivent donc
s'adapter mais il existe une solution
bien plus près qu'on pense
dans notre propre cour souvent il ya
beaucoup de belles choses à voir aussi
donc au lieu de courir après les oiseaux
ben on laisse ces oiseaux venir à nous
[Musique]
marie-hélène haché est une scientifique
du regroupement québecoiseaux en ces
temps de confinement l'organisme
encourage les gens à s'intéresser à leur
mythologie est à noter les observations
faites autour de la maison
dans la cour ici c'est vraiment
exceptionnel
on a une maison j'attaque new york
chante je suis à côté de nous il ya des
carouges lexical bronze et des bruits
saunier débourrement gorge blanche
vacher à tête brune et beaucoup beaucoup
d'espèces
on a beaucoup du porno ah ouais
marie-hélène h et a même appliquer son
ami aux deux jours et c'est pour très
longtemps compte dans ma tête dans mon
objectif c'est de savoir reconnaître
libre et vous qui viennent chez moi tout
simplement
les observations d'oiseaux sont ensuite
collectées et transmises sur une base de
données internationale
la plateforme ibr de l'université
cornell dans l'état de new york
n'importe qui à travers la planète peut
ainsi partager ses observations si
j'avais à faire une liste d'observation
d'ici donc je note tous les oiseaux que
je voit ou entend se soumet son ipad
on peut avec notre téléphone et et les
gens leur faire une liste d'observation
en cinq minutes
pis et transmis directement à la base de
données j'ai des amis mots qui ont
compilé jusqu'à 150 espèces d'oiseaux
dans leur cour donc s'il ya un
émerveillement qui est associé à ce qui
est intéressant
l'ornithologue et professeur à
l'université laval andré desrochers et
celui qui va analyser les observations
faites par les participants du programme
deux québécoises au moins ma tâche ça va
être de faire ici au maire de faire des
palmarès des régions où on a eu le plus
sûr mythologue en participer au projet
quels sont les oiseaux qui ont été vus
le plus fréquemment dans les cours
chez les gens une décidé qu'il fascine
c'est de faire la comparaison justement
entre qu'est ce qui se voit dans les
cours puis qu'est-ce qu'ils soient
ailleurs dans un milieu urbain mais
aussi à l'extérieur des milieux urbains
est ce que certaines espèces ont
beaucoup plus de chances de se retrouver
dans la cour chez les gens ou beaucoup
moins
[Musique]
tout ce projet repose donc sur ce que
l'on appelle la science participative où
tout le monde peut fournir des données
car s'il en est au logis se base sur un
travail scientifique de terrain les
données recueillies par la participation
citoyenne comme suri birds sont très
utiles pour la recherche les projets
science participative sont sont
importants parce que nous permet de
récolter des données le horizon de temps
vraiment élargie sur plusieurs années
puis sur des grandes superficies comme
l'ornithologie au québec là on habite
ornitho quand un peu partout aux quatre
coins de la province
alors si c'est un énorme avantage de
science participative dans nos projets
en écologie des paysages acoustique
particulièrement sur les communautés
d'oiseau on utilise aussi beaucoup les
données les braxois public comme
libourne et ça ça nous permet en fait de
regarder les grandes tendances dans les
communautés d'oiseaux est ce qu'il ya
des espèces qui sont en déclin est ce
que des espèces qui sont en augmentation
à trois rivières raphaël proulx étudie
d'ordinaire l'état des populations
d'oiseaux
grâce à des enregistrements sonores
en ces temps de covile 19 il joint ses
forces à un autre projet de science
participative celui des sites et
silencieuse car en cette période de
ralentissement des activités humaines
un paysage acoustique inédit s'offre à
nous l'objectif c'est de vraiment d'être
par mesure de caractériser le niveau de
pollution acoustique dans les villes
dans un premier temps et aussi ultime en
de regarder si l'effet de réduire la
pollution acoustique en ville peut avoir
des effets sur le comportement des
animaux à partir d'un enregistrement
n'est capable d'aller chercher
énormément d'informations et avoir
vraiment un portrait assez raffiné de la
biodiversité
chez les groupes qui émettent des sons
comme par exemple les oiseaux les
insectes chantants
la pollution par le bruit est de plus en
plus documenté mais c'est l'adaptation à
cette pollution sonore qui intéresse le
chercheur ce ce que ça fait c'est que ça
limite la transmission des sons et ça
peut limiter la communication entre les
animaux et donc on sait que les animaux
vont devoir s'adapter soit par exemple
en chantant plus fort ou en chantant la
des fréquences plus aiguë on sait par
exemple que les maisons charbonnières en
europe
chante dans des fréquences plus aiguë en
ville que dans les champs pour
contrecarrer la pollution acoustique
qu'en sera-t-il ici des analyses sonore
et géographique prendront du temps mais
elles permettront d'avoir une idée plus
précise de l'impact de ce changement
acoustique sur les espèces mais sans
grande analyse de la réduction du bruit
on croit déjà percevoir des changements
les jeunes mâles souvent on dirait que
plus d'oiseaux cette année
on n'entend plus les oiseaux
moi je crois que si on voit plus
d'oiseaux si on les entend plus sait
seulement qu'il ya moins de bruits
alentours puis aussi qu'on a plus de
temps libre
donc on ne plus on porte tous attention
à ce qui est autour de nous
[Musique]
quand nos activités ralenti ce que
l'environnement est moins bruyant et que
le temps paraît long porter attention à
la biodiversité peut s'avérer une
retombée positive de cette pandémie
[Musique]
parce que c'est le temps de découvrir
les oiseaux qui sont chez nous parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup
j'espère que ça à ross mais quand même
une petite virée chez certaines
personnes puis que ces gens là vont
continuer à observer les oiseaux c'est
vraiment une source incroyable
d'apprentissage de joie au circuit juste
le fait d'entendre des chants des
oiseaux ça fait beaucoup de bien